I'm June Sarpong and I'm the author of
diversified I was disabled for four
years of my life when I was a teenager I
was hit by a car didn't walk for two
years and then I had to wear a neck
brace for another two the thing that was
just so strange about it for me was the
way people reacted towards me after the
accident the way people treated meals I
almost saw a kind of dumbing down it was
the most bizarre thing and I think that
experience is what has made me so
passionate about this issue because I
wasn't any different as a person but the
world certainly reacted to me in that
way this is a quote from George Bush not
somebody I quote often and this quote
was in relation to african-american kids
in the inner cities that what he spoke
about was the soft bigotry of low
expectations and that really applies to
either say welcoming
we've looked at gender we've looked at
Bain we're now looking at disability
could you imagine having 500 Sheryl
Sandberg's leaning in for disability and
with disability we would get this done
if we want disability to be meaningfully
at the business table we need the
leaders it's got truly the uncomfortable
truth is they don't exist I believe and
many do to the diversity and inclusion
agenda is very difficult for business
when we're pushing humanity against each
other this year we'll do gender now you
will be race well do next year it will
do LGBTQ what are we talking as a la
carte and pick-and-mix
inclusion are you kidding me since when
did we think it was okay to have a
hierarchy of exclusion or inclusion my
name's Erin Boyce I work at Alliance
learning and I'm a business owner
ministry so apparently in a princess I'm
registered blind I have a condition
called retinitis pigmentosa actually I
moved out in the parents house about a
week after I left college I really felt
determined to get out and start living
this new chapter of my life so that was
in July that I left and I moved out I
thought my prospects were pretty
positive about getting a job and then I
was applying to things and I wasn't
getting anything at all and at this
point I was still putting my visual
impairment on my CV I felt like it was
all framed in a positive way
and it shouldn't have put them off but I
didn't get any kind of response at all
and then in October I decided to take
that off my CV and I got two interviews
that month and I didn't put it on again
I went to 18 interviews and for most
people asked the give up point and I
didn't because I've really still wanted
to work so I kept going for it but I
know a lot people who have given up and
those are people that are perfectly able
to work and if you reached out to them
and you said hey we know this employer
is accepting we know that they are
willing to make adaptations may you
should apply to them you're going to get
higher quality applicants because
actually I know in the case of visually
impaired people in general there is
actually a higher rating than going to
university
than the general public because they
know that their chances of getting a job
were much worse so they go into higher
education more often I really do think
it is a massive opportunity for
employers and it's it's something being
on the inside now you know having this
opportunity to hopefully make a
difference if I can't having had my
personal experience I'm trying now to
actually get us to tap into that because
I think they're just there's this
massive amount of high-quality
applicants out there you know and
they're more resilient and more loyal
when you slog through all these
interviews and you've had all these
things said to you and you feel like
Arthur garbage and then somebody treats
you like you're not a burden for once
and they're willing to make all these
adaptations for you you know what you've
got at that point so Allen here we have
the statistics relating to disability
and employment in Britain that's right
Woodleigh bleaker than any of the other
dates that we've looked at well it
depends how you look at it I mean one
thing I could say is we could we could
start with a good news story leave which
is that if you look at from when the
figures that we've got that we can go
back as far as 2013 there's a consistent
trend in the employment rate of disabled
people consistent increase yeah both for
men and for women and in fact the
employment rate of women with disability
you can see it's actually accelerated a
little bit faster than the employment
rate for men with disability yeah and
crucially has crossed this 50 percent
line for the past the first time so the
employment rate overall for both men and
women is now over 50% but just just over
50% and so and we would not be
celebrating that for any other group
exactly so in fact that's exactly where
this this term the disability employment
gap pops up because that line now looks
slightly less impressive that's the same
data we've just been looking at yeah
starting at zero and finishing at 100 so
this is the entire scale of the chart
and you can see that it's a very modest
improvement but I mean the real putting
those numbers into context really only
happens when you put the employment rate
for people without disability on top
okay and so you can see that there
really is this yeah this thing and this
is what we're calling the Disability
Employment gap and if you look at how
those figures have changed since 2013
there's been a modest narrowing of the
gap it was thirty three point one
percentage points by 2013 it's now down
to 28 point nine percent my name is
Stephanie Stevenson and I am a freelance
reporter for Sky Sports alongside my
reporting I'm also an athlete I don't
like to stop I'm quite busy I just want
to live life to the full and I want to
make the most of life pyjama here we are
at Sky your place of work my place of
work sometimes - I'm gonna ask you what
sounds like a very dumb question but for
employers how do they we advertise the
disabled people so what is that what
what is the thing that they need to do
to make it very clear that this is who
they're targeting I mean I think for me
it's all very well having these training
seems like I I went through a training
scheme myself however it was a very
negative experience because the whole
atmosphere wasn't inclusive originally
to start with okay I think they're a
good idea but I'm also very cynical of
them because you can have all these
great you know inclusive training
schemes to get people into the workplace
to show them what it's like to give them
experience so that they can linger in a
job but the workplace to start with it's
not an inclusive workplace you're not
going to retain those staff one thing I
find about Sky is they're very inclusive
they treat me as an individual I'm seen
as a reporter first before a wheelchair
user who happens to be a reporter which
is so important yeah
whether you're reporter like myself or
whether you're working in HR or an
administration you are working in a
chart you are working administration
you're working in media before your
disability I use the social model of
disability which is the favoured version
amongst the disabled community so it's
not saying that my illness makes me
disabled it's
the environment around me filming it
yeah makes me disabled what's your
message to employers and particularly HR
directors in terms of what they can do
when they are creating an application
and also making sure that that
application reaches people with
disabilities and then secondly once they
do hire people with disabilities make
sure that they're able to thrive within
their companies I think my biggest point
would be treat everybody as an
individual ah one thing oh no no no this
is powerful yeah so it's not about
treating everybody equally as such it's
treating everybody as an individual
understanding that we all have
individual needs because we all have
different needs to be equal to achieve
equality is really based on treating
everybody as an individual yeah it's
very much talk to the person because we
as disabled people are very good at
communicating because you have to we
have to yeah and you know what we know
it's not going to be perfect you know we
know it's never you were not striving
for perfection we're just driving for a
way to work that enables every version
exactly and things will go wrong even in
the most inclusive environments things
will go wrong but you know what makes
the difference between an employer I
want to stay with it and an employer I
want to leave behind the difference is
is that they listen to me hi my name is
Caroline Casey and I'm the founder of
the valuable 500s
in the bay meh pisode we talked about
the dangers of blanket turn yeah when
you love all people of color together
when the lived experiences are so
different yeah
the same applies to disability whether
solute whether it's physical sensory or
cognitive it's a very different lived a
very quiet or congenital there you go
you've just talked about fame or the
soft victory look or some finding out
this conversation about disability is no
different right this is not rocket
science sport I find very interesting to
your question about why is the issue of
disabilities so on the edges of business
is because of the fear of the complexity
the fear of getting it wrong and
actually I'll be really honest they
would rather try and deal with things
that may be simpler and more
straightforward and easy because can you
imagine what a business has to deal with
in trying to get it all right and I've
noticed with with disability they say
but what to do what do we do Caroline
what do we do and I'm like but what did
you do when we you started to have the
conversation about the environment what
did you do when you start up the
conversation about gender surely you
looked at what's happening in your
business and what's happening elsewhere
like what what did people outside you
did you go to experts did you talk to
the cohort of people because the most
important thing about disability is just
ask yeah just as I don't know you're
left experiences you don't know what
mine is but we can have the conversation
when you look at the employment rates
for different types of disability you
realize that looking at averages is very
dangerous because actually the some
disabilities like hearing the employment
rates well over sixty percent yes but
actually down here we've got things like
epilepsy mental illness speech yeah
exactly and those rates are very very
different so in fact when you look at
the average that we were just looking at
which is just over half 51% you can see
there's the disability employment gap
than we were looking at but look at
these people here with these kinds of
disabilities that gap is more we're near
nowhere near we from the average of
people with disabilities in general
exactly so so with something like
epilepsy only you know the employment
rates around about 33 I would have
thought there are certain forms of
disability was the thing with this is
obviously people are self identifying a
lot of people who cover their
disabilities one of the things that
caroline casey was talking about this is
something she did herself i would have
thought there are a lot of these forms
of disabilities that people probably
don't actually report yeah i mean that's
one of the weaknesses of a self-reported
survey which is that you're entirely
reliant on someone submitting that
information and i mean i think even with
physical disabilities looking at this
data the thing that's really interesting
is not one of these categories actually
reaches the employment rate anyway of
course the other thing that we can talk
about with this is that what we're
seeing here is our best data that we
have on this at the moment but it's
nowhere near like as comprehensive as
the data we would get for something like
the gender yeah well we're asking
companies to report this is this is a
quarterly survey arm do you think that's
the sort of thing that needs to happen
do you think that we need reporting on
there's obviously there's discussions
around reporting on vein and PEG absent
i think there's certainly the same
arguments that you could make you know
historically until we got the gender
reporting and now with the pressure for
beim i think you can make exactly the
same arguments for disability partly
because what we've been looking at up to
now is just the employment rates and
this general pattern that physical
disabilities have slightly higher
employment rates generally than mental
yeah but in fact the
the equalities and Human Rights
Commission have carried out some
analysis of the disability pay gap okay
that takes us much more into this
territory we're thinking well where do
we start talking about a requirement for
companies to report can we talk about
the role legislation has to play so very
important I'm very interested in some of
the stuff that's going on in China in
terms of actually mandating large
businesses to make sure that a
percentage of their workforce is from
the disabled community what are your
thoughts on that kind of leadership the
question comes up what I'm worried about
on the closure systems in many of the
OECD countries you have these quotas and
about employment figures which are often
around 10% yeah representation the i'ma
body and fines if you don't mean 50% of
them pay the fines I know yeah into
their training budget yeah so then
there's no point having legislation if
we are not going to stand over our
legislation yes I'm Jana cacar the
global managing partner of Dahlberg
it was wonderful to have your team
observe the round table and sort of take
away the nuggets and then compile a to
do an action point for CEOs and hrs
often there's a real focus on am i
recruiting a sufficiently diverse group
or and you know am i incentivizing them
sufficiently but understanding how
diversity drives better team performance
and then how to incentivize diversity
across the lifecycle once you have a
diverse set of employees that's where
the trick is you think about what's the
value what's the performance value that
we're talking about from diversity and
inclusion it's the diversity of the
thought and the decision-making and and
the risk aversion and stopping group
thinking about I mean we still have on
those dimensions of diversity pretty
poor measurement and metrics beyond that
identifiable characteristics and it's
good that we're doing a better job of
recording those when it comes to
personality differences cognitive
differences yes yes
still at the foothills of thinking about
how to get a fix on that when yielding
genuinely diverse teams across all its
dimensions the composition of the the
the balance of characters in the team is
so critical exactly and the notion as
Pamela was saying of genuinely
team-based yes recruitment performance
evaluation and promotion that's we're
still a world away from
[Music]
ignition is a brewery in southeast
London we have a taproom as well and we
sell draught of ale and bottled ale our
secret is that our staff team have
learning disabilities but the beer that
make is so good that we're able to sell
it and pay them the London living wage
of 1055 an hour Wow I mean we've been
looking at the data in relation to
people with disabilities in the
workplace and particularly learning
disabilities that group in particular
earn the least and are the least likely
to be employed is that why you decided
to focus on that's that side of
disability sort of so yeah you're
absolutely right is it was 94% of had no
job yeah they actually stopped measuring
it I think the government has given it
so bad that's the point you're trying to
sell an idea and I think what we've
learnt about this is it's about people
people employ people and also to create
the kind of culture where your employees
can thrive because if you're taking
somebody with learning disabilities into
an environment that isn't prepared for
them sometimes you can be doing that
employee to service so what's wonderful
about here is you've created the kind of
environment that's inclusive enough for
all your employees to thrive oh thank
you I think it matters
I think what's good about this is
actually a lot of the changes that we've
made in comparison to places where I've
worked before actually got a much
healthier culture and I've now gone and
employed those in places where I will
work you know and and it's a lot of the
things we've had to do about you know
being patient or getting a good routine
or having a healthy the way in which you
talk to each other thing really healthy
are actually just things anyone should
do and I think we are an extreme version
of what I'd like the world to be our
team is obviously very special and but I
think the impact that someone can have
with a learning disability for the
better in your business is really good
because it's great for morale it's also
great for sort of I think getting people
just to behave better I think actually
I'm a work yeah and I used to show good
example I need to be a better person
you're an economist by trade but you
think that also influenced your decision
to actually do something about this
problem knowing how many people are out
of work and how much we're losing out on
as an economy as a result of that yeah
so it was a kind of it's a financial
gamble in a way I thought right the best
way to show that you know our guys can
generate you profit and income is
yeah and so we've taken people with no I
have no bearing experience they have no
brewing experience I'm not mad about
beer I quite like our beer and actually
we've created a business that is surplus
making and you know is a good employer
based on their talents for anybody
wanting to replicate your model for
corporations who want to look at doing
something like this on a larger scale
what are the pitfalls what are the
difficulties because let's be frank
about that too so I think it's a big
cultural change on me all we all know
culture changes the hardest yeah it's
really difficult and there needs to be
buying at the top is the first thing so
you know the top honcho they need to say
I'm really committed to this and we're
going to make it happen and without that
it won't happen and then I think there's
been a lot of the kind of systematize
ation of employment for people
disability so you know this guy there's
a checklist and they make them interview
ready then there's a CV ready thing and
we just largely discarded that what
we've done is we've started very much
with the people and said do you want to
work with us are you really key yeah yes
okay we'll come and just do a shift
because actually that's the best way for
us to learn because even if they can't
do any of it that's fine you can but you
can tell if the aptitude is there and if
they sort of go okay because pulling a
pint is actually really well I find it
really hard but you can tell if
someone's gonna keep on going till they
get it and then one forget it they've
got it
[Music]
if you want to truly as suppose maximize
the performance potential of your
diverse teams you bring them on board
and then you identify where are they're
sort of hidden constraints to top
performance where are there ways in
which diversity which we know has been
statistically proven to be a key driver
of financial performance I mean it was
shocking to me to see that it was so so
well quantified it literally it's a
percentage to to of of increased
financial performance if you have a
diverse team and you can just see that
you know the the needle go up and down
but yet they still resist there but you
know it's it's you sort of we've we
spend enough time I think on the
diagnosis or the demonstration of the
business case okay but then committing
and executing the action is that if
that's what the next step yeah
okay so we have workforce let's talk
about customers and consumers mmm in
terms of what a CEO or leader in within
an organization can do to add value in
relation to diversity of customers the
interesting thing about customers or
consumers is it is it is an only a
medium known fact the degree to which
the diverse consumer is growing in
strength and buying power strength
decision-making power strength I found
it fascinating one of your and attendees
at the CEO roundtable Karen black it CEO
powerful CEO in her own right and she
said look you know over the last decade
we have seen minority buying power ago
from 30 odd billion to three hundred
billion pounds so let's just let's pause
and yeah yeah so shifting gears to say
well who is this diverse customer that I
have out there and I'm serving exactly
an understanding how do I actually
tailor myself my product my solution my
approach in order to capture them
the most provocative way to get anybody
in business interest is to look at our
bottom line yeah so let's just talk
about the UK okay you're worth two
hundred and forty nine billion that is
what this disability community is worth
there's massive competition going on
those high streets why are you not
listening I think it's a really
interesting when we see that
supermarkets you know supplying for the
400,000 vegans yeah because they see
this value right okay but but let's be
honest because they see this value well
20 percent of the population here so I
think Barclays have have always made the
intention very clear they want to be the
most accessible and inclusive fat C
company hmm
and they do that through could their
consumer offering hmm but the best
example of all time for any of this is
Apple really why Hausa
because see Bob as we know was probably
very difficult but he was a visionary
and he wanted to create the most
beautiful products that everybody else
in the world could use mmm that's called
universal design mmm Apple was the very
first brand in the world to reach 1
trillion mmm why do you think that is
it's because there are more of us who
can use their products mmm actually
Apple is a brand that most of the
disabled community will choose so was
that a consideration when they were
designing he just beautiful ideas for
everyone now they don't shout about
being an inclusive or an accessible
comfort it's the universal design
sometimes we forget that if we get
design right for the full spectrum of
disability yeah we'll probably get it
right for all of us I kind of think the
business case to incentivize businesses
let me just tell you it's an 8 trillion
market it's a brand opportunity it's an
uncluttered space it's the acquisition
retention of talent it's about
innovation its productivity next
generation really care about spending
money and working with companies that
allow you to be who you are why have we
not seen accelerated change I'll go back
to where we began because the most
powerful force in this planet is making
a decision to leave the disability
community
an invisible market and unless it gets
into this game meaningfully invest in it
we will continue to see no matter what
no matter what legislation you do in the
world because let's be honest money runs
the world power money business
it affects politics and I don't think
any legislation will be able to solve
this if business don't take
responsibility but and take up the
opportunity I believe diversity has a
triple line benefit to business for
innovation productivity and bottom line
it's a triple line belch the individual
to society in a piece at large and to
the business bottom line I mean what is
not to the hype